[Musique]
allez-y
Plus
[Applaudissements]
h
Moi je veux
chanter des choses qui sont jolies des
gens qui s'aiment d'amour et des yeux
par des milliers de personnes qui savent
sourit Moi Je veux
chanter le bon coté de la
rue O IL et un du
Soleil mme si c'est trop joli pour ere
vrai
Oh oui, toi
fais-moi chanter pot
tu es
sympa remets du bleu Sur tes
paroles un
gago ton
balcon oublie les l Ur
monotone
thé sanglant
[Musique]
violan peux
chanter des choses qui font du bien des
mots qui viennent d'ailleurs et des
les étés qui reviennent
D'exil Moi Je veux chanter des rayon
de joie des brassé de Lila mme si c'est
trop joli pour utt tre
vrai
Oh toi le pote Je compte Sur toi s'il te
pla tu es
sympa On Un baiser pour notre
quelques cours
fleurs Sud
chemin n cul soifer de l'au de
source auxiliaire
affame un peu de
pain Moi Je veux
chanter des choses qui sont jolies des
gens qui s'aiment d'amour et dess yeux
par des milliers de personnes qui savent
souris Moi Je veux
chanter le bon coté de la rue l o il y
à du Soleil mme si c'est trop joli pour
entre
vrai Moi Je veux
chanter des choses qui font du
bien et puis tout et
tout
Moi je veux
chanteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans